good morning everybody
i think we are set to go here um it is a
few minutes after 10 o'clock
today is friday
april 25th the chair is just checking
her phone to make sure the volume is
oh the 22nd see there you go i needed to
check my phone for more than the time
um
so welcome everybody this is the new
hampshire house
redistricting committee uh we have a
public hearing scheduled this morning on
sb 200 and a non-germain amendment
before we begin consideration of those
items i ask that you all rise and join
me in the pledge of allegiance
i pledge allegiance to the flag of the
united states of america and to the
republic for which it stands one nation
under god indivisible with liberty and
justice for all
as stated this morning is a hearing on
sb 200
uh
and
the prime sponsor of the of this bill is
senator gaida but here with us to
introduce it this morning
is senator gray welcome senator guerilla
thank you madam chair and committee
i'm here to introduce
sb 200
as written it deals with
increasing the number of
commissioners from
three to five in one particular location
you have already provided us with
legislation that gives blanket approval
not just in one community
so that this bill
as written is unnecessary
and that if you have desires to use that
bill for something else
feel free
thank you very much senator gray there
are any questions for senator gray
i'll be back at 10 30. thank you very
much
i think we might be gone by 10 30 just
so you know
um i have two people signed up to speak
on the amendment that has been noticed
for today i have no one else signed up
to speak on sb 200 excuse me madam chair
yeah
the amendment has been noticed for 10
30.
thank you
is there anybody
here who wants to speak to sb 200.
all right we're getting more
um
items in so we will be back in we will
take a recess until 10 30.
good morning everyone again it is 10 30.
um we are still live
um with the reporting
um and i am reopening the meeting at
this time we have a hearing scheduled on
a non-germane amendment
uh your chair is the sponsor of that
non-germain amendment
and she will be stepping down from the
chair of this meeting so that the vice
chair can conduct the hearing on the
non-germain amendment since i am the
sponsor before the meeting actually
opens with the non-germain amendment
understand as chair that i consider
that this committee has available to it
the entire calendar to work on bills and
issues relating to redistricting
and accordingly even though we have
passed a congressional map uh earlier
and we
know that it is going to be vetoed or
expected to be vetoed so i don't believe
it's actually happened yet so we have
time to continue our work and that of
course is why we have re-noticed this
meeting
and this committee to convene and
committee members should have received
notice of a meeting next week
where i expect that we will be having
executive session on bills
that relate to what i hope to be the
subject matter of sb 200 if we get
through the hearing on my non-germain
amendment which will be
congressional district mapping so with
that
thank you for your attention and i'm
turning the meeting over to
vice chair representative steve smith
all right we well that's loud we will
open the uh
public hearing on amendment 1523h
and remember this is a public hearing it
is not a work session
it's not an executive session the
purpose of this hearing is to hear
testimony for or against the amendment
welcome representative griffin
thank you chair smith
my name is barbara griffin i am a
representative to the new hampshire
house
representing the town of goffstown
and i have presented for you today an
amendment which i have managed to come
up here without
um i believe you have it all in your
possession with the number on top of it
you have been provided a copy of that
amendment along with thank you
senator gray this would be amendment
1523h
and it is an amendment to sb 200 which
you heard senator gray testified to
earlier this morning my intent
with this
amendment
and the noticing that has occurred
is to have a public hearing on this
matter so that this committee will have
a vehicle to continue its work in
regards to
the map so at this point maybe christine
could you help me pass these out
um what i'd like to do is while i know
you have a map in front of you oh let me
keep the top one
i
i have um some maps for you to consider
as we speak about the amendment in front
of you
um for you to consider and and what
you're getting now is
um a governor sununu the proposed map
that is in front of you it's actually
labeled governor sununu and i'll talk
about that in a minute
and it sort of details exactly what you
have in front of you from staff only it
provides you
a pictorial
with county lines because um there does
seem to be some in my opinion obsession
with the pictorial of a map
without any um understanding of the
population shifts that occur
so this map
that you have in front of you and the
amendment
um
you and i found out about together
um on march 22nd
this map was presented
to both the president of the
senate and the speaker of the house from
the governor's office in regards to
a proposal for a draft congressional
redistricting map
it was pointed out that it was not the
only solution i think this committee is
well aware that any map
mapping exercise that you're basing on
population can
can have a number of outcomes
and
in this particular case
the governor's office and this is a
matter of public record
indicated that their
his standards at that time were
competitive passes the smell test
and
[Music]
i
describes it as being um
[Music]
something not immune from challenges or
constituent services
um what he did point out is that there's
still time to get the work done and
that's what we're here to begin
so what you see in front of you is the
map is proposed
as you can see
it
splits
some counties
and
um the reality is is that when the
population of this map just so you're
aware
is actually
looked at it has a deviation of slightly
over a thousand
we know from
law that
in congressional district mapping
the numbers are very important there are
some circumstances in fact where
other factors can
override
the deviation issue in regards to
congressional map but in the first
instance before this committee i think
we have looked at deviations and
that is what we've been considering
i'm not going to describe the outline of
this map
um it is what it is i i have been amused
not amused i have noted that many people
try to ascribe characteristics
of maps as to what they may or may not
look like and i have to tell you
as somebody with an msw i always wonder
whether we're doing a raw shot ink test
or
um exactly what it is we're trying to do
when we try to describe a map
pictorially referring to other objects
um
what we have also heard a lot about is
the regards to the fact that things need
to be changed and christina i can just
pass it out at the end
and build the extras
i've also just so we all understand you
remember i said something about the the
deviations
um
is the present day map
so
the present-day map
which
there has been
some discussion
about how it doesn't really
need to change much
in order to meet the population issue
has a deviation
of approximately 1200 i believe
which accounts for some discussion about
changing something but
um
the reality is um
if we're we're starting to look at the
picture of the map as something
that we do these other tests from
um
i don't i don't we have this big sort of
arm into it so so the question then
becomes
um we had a lot of discussion about
where we began and i think in the past
hundred years things really haven't
changed so
i also have for the committee
what did the 1880 map look like
so as we all continue to do our work in
considering the map and as i consider
governor sununu's map which has been
presented to the committee to consider
and to hear public testimony
how did we get to
to having this corner of the state be
the map and so if we look back to 1880
that was apparently what looked like
approximately an equal deviation of the
state but today
that would be a deviation of
approximately 300 000 people
one of these districts
would be 300 000 people more today
so
as i i look of the progression and if
you look you know
astonishing
how little deviations to the border of
this have just continued
because apparently
historically we have not questioned the
starting point
and
i want to thank the governor for
presenting his map and the criteria
which in my struggles to understand
caused me to go back and review this
to consider why are we
why are we starting from where we are
when if i go back to 100 years and the
population shift in this state has been
that significant
shouldn't we be looking at something
maybe entirely new which i will just say
in my experience on local boards makes
me feel like i'm at a budget committee
meeting again when the management always
comes in with the budget starting from
last year's budget and the new budget
committee members always want to start
from zero
so it's an argument that occurs or a
different position that occurs in
consideration of a lot of things
so
i want to thank the committee and the
committee chair for allowing me the
indulgence of sharing with you what i
took a look at as i struggled
to determine whether or not
the map that had been proposed
made sense
as i said
that there is a deviation in population
and as i said there are certain
circumstances where that deviation may
not matter
but i think as this committee goes
forward i'm urging it to consider that
maybe we should
continue to try and strive to meet that
federal standard
and
with that
i am open to any questions with the
understanding that
i did not
actually draft this map
and i have not have any had any direct
discussions with anybody on the criteria
for drawing the map i just shared with
you my sort of struggles to understand
how it might make some sense
and what the history of the mapping was
thank you
thank you i just wanted to clarify
something you said in the need for
changing the current districts the
deviation was twelve hundred did you
mean twelve hundred or twelve thousand
twelve thousand i think energize
representative turcotte
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative for taking the question i
realize you are presenting the map that
was personally drawn by the governor
are you aware do you know if either the
governor or somebody from his uh
his team will be here to talk about and
explain
uh some of the rationales behind this
map my understanding is the governor had
a scheduling problem this year and there
will not be anybody from his office here
i spoke with somebody earlier today and
they will not be able to make it thank
you
further questions representative lane
thank you um
mr chair
representative griffin
um
what is the deviation on the governor's
map
uh is i think it's 1028
does anybody have the i think that's
what i came up with
i might be a little off
okay
representative barry do you know i don't
have the exact number in front of me but
i believe when i did it was roughly
twelve hundred people um well i thought
it was a thousand uh yeah g give or take
don't hold me to that exact number but i
believe it's i'm going for going off of
memory
i have a follow-up follow-up um
i don't recall what the deviation was on
the map that this committee
um
sent over to the senate do you know what
my recollection was it was less than 100
89 i think okay 88 and 89 respectively
because there's the uh senator gray
often refers to the um the forgotten
half person
okay okay
representative weber
thank you mr chair uh
could you tell us how many towns change
with respect to this map
no i could not
thank you
and if i could further answer frank
frankly i didn't really consider that
as a criteria because i'm not really
quite sure where we're starting from
and in my opinion
we're starting from drawing districts
that meet the criteria and in my
experience many people in my own
community don't even know what
congressional district they're in they
go and pull a ballot with candidates
that they've heard about
and the numbering of the district does
not matter to them i must ascribe a
little bit to that fault
because of course you might have noticed
ols comes back with different district
numbers
than we had on the maps sometime when
you're drafting a map and you submit it
the district numbers come back and i'm
always somewhat amused by people who
complain who are complaining about the
redistricting because all of their
representative labels have their
district number on it and now it's going
to change and i i'm fortunate i can
represent myself as one community
because i think my district number is 36
but i'm not sure
the issue was not what the district
number was it was just how many towns
had changed from
one district into the other but if you
don't know the answer to that that's
fine
further questions
representative lane
thank you mr chair representative
griffin um
do you know if the uh the incumbents
where they are if they were taken into
consideration when drawing this map i do
not know that that was taken into
account in drawing this map and if i
could just clarify i believe somebody
said that governor sununu drew that map
just so i'm clear i'm not i i this came
from governor sununu's office
um as we all know from the press release
and from the letter that was issued and
that would be the extent of my ability
to tell you the base of this map
follow up mr chair
yes
representative
even though it came from his office you
submitted it so you've had no
conversations at all with
the governor about the map
i've had no conversations with the
governor representative lane
thank you as a committee chair i viewed
it my obligation to
the state to continue the process to
work on a map and i think the governor's
office for providing me
with a districting map that i could use
as a vehicle to amend the senate bill so
we have something that we can continue
our work
representative berry uh yes thank you mr
chairman uh and thank you um madam
chairman um for providing us with the
1880 map um and the reason i'm glad that
that has been circulated around is there
seems to be this uh obsession with
keeping things the way they are
so when i look at
the 1880 congressional map i look at the
present day map and i look at
the proposed map the amendment we're
speaking about today
my question and you probably don't know
the answer to this so i'm sorry for it's
i you probably don't know the answer but
i'm going to ask it anyways because it
seems to be a popular question how many
towns have moved
since 1880 to the governor's proposed
map
conversely how many towns have moved
since 1880 to the present day map
thank you for the question i do not have
an answer uh follow up mr chairman
follow up
um yes and so
you know to build off of what
representative lane said once again not
really fair to ask you about a map you
didn't draw um i see it's not stopping
you in the least representative barry so
proceed
i think i'm known i think i'm known for
that
the federal government doles out money
based on counties and county government
in new hampshire is notoriously weak
they basically handle the sheriff's
office the district courts uh and the
nursing homes and they'll and then
basically they hand out federal money in
fact we have a hillsborough county
delegation meeting coming up to discuss
arbor funding which is doled out via the
counties
and much of the fed which
much of what the federal government does
is based on counties and while new
hampshire doesn't do that really the
federal government does so
in the original 1880 map
we new hampshire only split two counties
they split merrimack county
and hillsborough county
the proposed map
by governor sununu we'll start with the
present day map splits grafton county
merrimack county merrimack county i'm
sorry sorry belknap county merrimack
county rockingham county and
hillsborough county so one two three
four five counties
and governor sununu's map all splits one
two three four counties um so 40 percent
of the counties in the state are broken
up um the original map once again
was two counties so my question is is in
taking into consideration the fact that
federal government doles out money by
county was there a consideration in
place to keep counties together given
that that's how the federal government
this is a congressional map doles out
the money
i can't say whether that was a
consideration in drawing the map but it
certainly would appear that the result
has some county differences that would
be impossible to deal with as an entire
entity i i would point out that
um there is county money from the feds
there is transportation money for
new construction uh franconia notch
um i-93 is the one we're most certainly
familiar with um and there's also
um money that comes in
not necessarily by county but through
hhs
which of course goes to
some of our
primarily major metropolis areas
i can keep going but somebody else wants
to ask a question
representative smith
thank you very much mr chairman smith
um
before i ask a question could anyone
help me
understand what this appendage is on the
southeast border
that extends past rockingham county
yeah i'm assuming that's the
the battled over territorial isle of
shoals area that we
in some circumstances can't relinquish
but i think the county i think that's
that's what i presumed i take the county
line as being the the state border with
the with the
yeah that that is not the uh the other
shows it's a little big for the isles of
shows yeah and it's also not in the
right place but other than that it's
fine
um i just um because i know all right
there you go there's pictures for maps
for you i noticed that it's on the
governor's map and also well well both
of the governor's maps i guess because
they are the same
um
uh
i actually didn't know until just
moments before that you
had an msw which shows why you're so
good with your people skills dealing
with difficult people
but you also i know have a law degree
and i wonder um as you've looked at the
changes over the years
whether you took into consideration um
baker versus carr which i think was 62
if i remember and westbury v sanders
which was 64
in which we have to have
equal population or as equal as possible
and i wonder if those were
considerations
that were taken in terms of drawing
these maps
i presumed that those were
considerations in drawing these maps but
given the population shift
that would exist today the population
deviation that would exist today
from the 1880 map
my question became why would i continue
to use a map that used that as a
starting point
if i could just follow up i don't think
oh
i'm sorry could i follow up mr chair
sure thing
thank you very much i appreciate that um
i'm not i'm curious as to several
mentions have been made
of
the appearance of a commitment
to that which has gone
before i'm not sure
that that's an accurate reflection of
how maps were drawn during this whole
process i know that the map
that um
the democratic members of this committee
submitted
um
was a map that
and this is a question i mean was a map
that certainly
considered that which has gone before
but ended up with population i think of
deviation of 50 if i
if i remember correctly
um and that an attempt was made to
follow
the legal requirements
and since we don't begin with a blank
slate
you know we're not going back to zero
each time um you begin with what you
have and then you see how do you change
that to make sure you're meeting
legal requirements tell me what's wrong
with that approach
representative smith i would not presume
to speak to
the bases of what other members might
have proposed and why unless it's on the
record and people can review the record
for itself i would simply comment on
your last section of last statement
which is we don't start from zero or
scratch and i would go back to what i
previously said in regards to the
freshman member of a budget committee
who asks why am i not starting to create
this budget from zero based on need and
what fits the needs today as compared to
working off the budget of yesteryear and
deciding what needs to be changed
there's simply two different approaches
in an exercise that needs to be done on
your municipal and state level from a
financial standpoint and every 10 years
in regards to districting and i and i
certainly would defer to you as to
considerations of what have gone on in
previous cons previous mapping exercises
in this state as i know you have been
very involved in it
as have you thank you very much manager
all right so we've kept her up there for
25 minutes and it's kind of starting to
feel like a work session to me so
representative turcotte
thank you mr chairman thank you again
for taking the question
at the beginning of this entire
redistricting process members of this
committee were given an extraordinary
extraordinary amount of reading material
based on
previous state and federal court cases
i just like to ask your opinion on this
particular map that if it went uh if it
was challenged in court
do you think it would be immediately
found
on the deviation alone would that be
enough to have this
map thrown thrown out
uh i would not presume to say what i
think the judicial branch would do with
what is a legislative branch function
um but i certainly know that would be a
consideration that would be briefed
thank you
representative piedra
i was just
wondering representative i can't tell
from your testimony whether you actually
support this particular proposal can you
clarify
i think we can do better
follow up
is it your intention then
to offer additional amendments at next
week's
uh meeting
well it's my intention at some point if
the public hearing on this amendment
ends is to resume my status as chair of
this committee and then to announce that
since we have another executive session
that i'm hoping that members will feel
free to bring forward further amendments
um and get them into the
to the body in order that they can be
noticed
online at least a day before our
executive session next week
representative barry thank you mr
chairman this will uh thank you for the
indulgence this will be my last one so
not to enter into a work session
thank you madam chairman
looking at the proposed amendment it
looks like the only economic community
that is kept together by this map is the
seacoast
and when you look at the 1880 proposal
um
1880 congressional map that kept
together the sea coast uh all of the
lakes region
um
and if you also understand the
populations it kept basically kind of
your major population centers together
um because populations have changed over
the last 18 of the last 100 and quick
math 40 years um my question is about
the proposal
it looks like only the seacoast together
so why weren't more economic communities
considered in this why wasn't the
greater manchester community considered
why wasn't the greater concord community
considered why is the lakes region
broken up um with the loss of center
harbor do you have it were you given an
explanation about why these major
economic communities were separated
as i said i've had no conversations with
the governor at all in regards to
consideration of this map
um but i would like to say to the
committee i think that question
highlights what you've all done and i
want to thank you all for your work
because um simply dealing with the
population and the program that we had
which worked i think quite well
didn't really give you a huge amount of
information other than
a district number and what population
you were shifting
thank you representative griffin thank
you very much thank you to the members
of the committee
next up
representative horrigan on support of
the amendment
um
thank you very much mr chair and um so
i'm representing timothy horrigan from
stratfor county's district six the towns
of durham and madbury the same
district uh represented by the other
representative smith
and um
so it
it pains me to to agree with the
governor probably almost as much as it
pains you to have to rewrite the
congressional district map but i think
this um
i guess the senate redistricting
committee was probably like even more
imaginative you were but we've seen some
rather imaginative maps being drawn this
year especially um
we're not talking about the executive
council map but i
still scratching my head over that one
even though we voted on it yesterday but
this is a
um
very uh
compact map um it
depending on how you look at it either
fails to split um
uh six out of the states ten counties or
it keeps ten six of the ten counties
intact and it only makes
pretty minor changes to belknap it just
takes the small town of center harbor
out of there presumably make the numbers
work better and
even carroll county only takes for
communities what's going with hillsboro
is they're taking
um
i'm telling you something probably you
all
can see for yourselves but they're
taking manchester and goffstown and
immediately they're putting the
immediate environs of manchester in
in cd1 which is where they've been for
over
almost a century and a half now and also
which also means that uh the uh the
incumbent can continue to run in the
district that he lives in and all the
many candidates on the other side are
running
vying for the republican nomination um
are also still living in the
district that they lived in so that's um
i mean if you uh
you know
if for some reason you feel the need to
split more counties you could probably
put a couple towns in grafton or
stratford like milton is right on the
border if you want to
do that while you're
making the numbers come out better i
think
um
which reminds me in terms of county
government represent barry uh i'm not
sure what he
said was entirely correct i said on the
judiciary committee
here in concord i'm also the chair of
the general government's subcommittee in
stratfor county so we do a lot more than
he um
than he said said we did
but on the other hand um we're not
responsible at all for the courts the
district well the superior court
districts are drawn along county lines
but they're they've
for
we've reorganized the courts a number of
years and they're now
run by this at the state level same goes
for all the district courts and most of
those also obey counting lines but there
are
i think there are a few minor exceptions
like i think there's a uh
district in grafton county that bleeds
over into carroll county but that's um
i think respecting the county lines it's
a good idea just because the voters they
do have
they still have some identity even um
even if their government functions and
not as much in other states but people
do know which county they live in and
especially if you're a political
activist one of the two major parties
like i am
you know
which county committee is yours and so
forth there's a lot of value to keeping
the counties
the counties intact in fact it'd
probably be even possible to
swap center harbor with some other town
and then keep belknap county entirely
within one congressional district and
the um
sort of the old district i think the
district the district of the governor i
guess he hasn't actually vetoed it yet
but everybody believes he is going to uh
to veto it um
split uh
quite a few counties and um you know was
just you know divided all kinds of
communities together it was like pretty
a huge departure from
[Music]
huge huge departure from how it's been
in the past and i don't think um
at least most of us most of us who
aren't in the majority of the uh senator
house redistricting committees have no
idea why why you drew it that way it was
um seemed very strange although
regardless of how you draw it we have
two
very purple districts which um will be
in play for either parties that you know
i think probably you know the uh
not the f2 parties in here or not about
federal campaigns too much but you know
the incumbent district one is a very
he's very uh popular and strong uh
figure he probably would have won just
about any district we could have uh
drawn for him so the um
so i i definitely i've not talked to the
governor about this the fact that
governor and i
um we know each other but we we never
talk about anything actually like so he
um so he definitely didn't talk to me
i'm probably one of the last people the
state house he would want to talk to me
about it but wendy's
i have a lot of respect for him and i
think sometimes he does
does something right and i think with
this plan this is um this is something
right it's the best it's a vast
improvement over of the
the previous plan and i would certainly
urge you you know you can if you want to
tweak it at me
move a few towns around that might make
it even better but um
i think it's good as is and
any plan you brought there'd be court
challenges to you to it but i don't
think uh i don't think this one is more
likely to be challenged if it has
a deviation of 1200 as was set today or
whatever it is rather than 88 so that
that's not enough to get the plan um
planned thrown out in federal court and
finally i might add i read today that 46
out of the 50 states have done their
congressional redistricting plan and
many of them have a much more difficult
task because
we're one of the few states where we
have to stick with the municipal and
city ward boundaries most states can go
down to the block level which uh you
know adds makes the whole several orders
of magnitude more complicated
um god help us if we had to do a plan
that went down to the block level um
we'd probably never get it done so we're
so
even though we're the greatest state in
the union with the greatest legislature
it does sort of uh surprise me a little
bit that
we're lagging behind 46 other states
when we only really have
two districts to draw and no matter how
we draw them um
you know we're not
no matter how hard we try to gerrymander
those two districts just because of the
way representative yes so it's not
proper to assume that anybody in the
room is attempting to gerrymandering i
understand the process is long and if
you could loop your comments back into
the amendment before us oh well let's
it's going on on the national scene is
not a topic well it's an excellent
amendment um i think it's a great
improvement over the previous plan and
certainly
even
even the version we passed in the house
was probably not unconstitutional i
believe it probably would withstand a
score challenge but this one um
this one is also not unconstitutional
also i believe would not withstand a
court challenge and i think it's i think
it's better than
what we're looking at so
hopefully that's uh
hopefully that's an acceptable comment
so
thank you anybody thanks so
as i said i definitely didn't talk to
the governor about this and
thanks questions from the committee
okay thank you thanks
next up corinne dodge
opposing the amendment
good morning vice chair
and members of the special redistricting
committee
my name's coreen dodge
maybe i should do this
and i vote in derry
for the record i am an independent voter
i vote for candidates who i believe will
represent me
i am not going to speak to you today
about deviations and statistics
and map making skills because
i really don't know a lot about it
i'm going to be speaking to you as a
voter
and how
whatever district redistricting maps you
come up with how they will affect people
like myself
independent voters
democratic voters republican voters
we expect our vote to be counted fairly
that's my that's our criteria
government governor sununu's statement
yesterday
regarding congressional redistricting
maps has prompted me to add to my
prepared testimony
prior to the past years grass i'm sorry
prior to the past year grassroots
citizens
like myself worked here at the state
house to pass two separate bills for a
non-partisan redistricting commission to
prevent gerrymandering
we were told by state legislators then
that they would not support such a
commission because the commission would
not be responsible to the people
and only the state legislators had the
right to re redraw
redistricting maps
so we compromised
and the bills were finally passed in the
name of the people
twice
the governor vetoed the bills saying
that we don't have gerrymandering in new
hampshire so we don't need nonpartisan
redistricting commissions
you have proven him wrong
no we wouldn't be here doing this over
and over and over again
i believe that our democracy works
really well when legislators of all
political parties work together in
compromise
to create laws which truly represent all
new hampshire voters far better than any
one party could do on its own
far better than what the democratic
party could do
for them far better than what the
republican party could do all by itself
or any other party for that matter
i have seen i have not seen compromises
happening with our redistricting laws
this year
i believe
i believe that our government fails us
when legislators from one political
party any political party methodically
create redistricting laws for the
express purpose of putting their
political party in complete charge of
determining
what laws will be passed for the next 10
years
it fails us also when legislators choose
to vote to please and protect their own
party
political party bosses rather than
representing their constituents
i would like to remind this committee
that the new hampshire constitution of
clearly states that quote
all all government of right originates
from the people
is founded in consent
and instituted for the general good
furthermore article 8 clarifies
government accountability by stating
all power residing originally in
being derived from the people
all magistrates and offices of
government
are their substitutes and agents
and at all times accountable to them
government therefore should be open
accessible accountable and responsive
we the people your constituents have
been consistently asking for competitive
maps
based around communities of interest
i ask you again today will you make this
map competitive
while the
congressional districts in front of you
in the map in front of you are a bit
more competitive than the districts
awaiting the governor's veto they are
still not as competitive as the maps we
already had in 2010
the population between the two districts
could easily be evened out by simply
swapping two towns
and epson i'm sorry an epsom
i remember the chair of this committee
assuring the public at her first meeting
that the maps created by this committee
would be fair
transparent and would not benefit any
one political party
since that time i have attended and
given testimony at countless meetings on
redistricting
at each of these public hearings
sorry
at each of these public hearings large
numbers of voters showed up
with an overwhelming call for
redistricting maps that represent all
voters of new hampshire and which do not
give unfair advantage to one political
party over another
in reply you have presented us with one
map after another which gives unfair
advantage to one political party i am
incredibly disappointed and angry that
our public requests
for redistricting maps this year have
been consistently ignored
i ask you again
please make the maps competitive
thank you you're welcome
next liz tentarelli
neither in support nor opposition to the
amendment if i have that right
thank you i think i wrote on the top of
this i'm ambivalent
i'm liz tentarelli i live in newbury i'm
president of the league of women voters
and i'm not ambivalent about demanding
fair maps so i will say that this
proposed map is a definite improvement
over the one that has passed through the
legislature because the districts are
more competitive
and i think that's a good thing and
that's what voters want
um but i'm not sure i can say
the rest of my testimony because
representative griffin
took my thunder when she said
i think we can do better
because as i was thinking about this in
the way down in the car i said
maybe i'll just try a one-sentence
testimony and say
you can do better
but it makes more more sense coming from
representative griffin
so i i hope you will do better
on a personal note i can't speak for
league here i have always thought that
the representatives to congress from our
state
should understand the whole state
they should understand the economies of
the cities
the needs of the suburban areas and
understand the rural needs
and the 2011 map
did include rural areas in district 1.
i thought that was important because
included there that meant that whoever
gets elected from that district needs to
be responsive to those constituents
and i don't know if it's still possible
to draw a map like that
where you do include some of those rural
areas but i think it makes a difference
i wish that
all congressional
representatives from all over the
country could represent that diversity i
realize they can't we've got huge cities
that have multiple reps
but i think here in new hampshire we
could do that i know you have had other
drafts you've had a mapathon proposal
you've had a minority proposal
and uh as representative griffin said i
too think that you can do better and i
hope you do so thank you
thank you
oh did you
are you willing to take questions
sure
representative barry thank you um a
quick question can you please define
what what your definition of competitive
is because one party has won 90 of the
contests in the last 10 years so
what is your metric for for competitive
because for me it's it's outcome what is
your definition i i am surprised that
that has happened frankly because i
don't think that the way the towns are
arranged
predetermined that district 2 would be
so cons and and has it been 10 years i
thought it was eight years but anyway
okay thank you for that correction um so
my definition of competitive is that
a good candidate from either party has a
reasonable chance of making progress in
the district
and we certainly have seen that in
district one
over the last 10 years it has flipped
back and forth several times
district one has changed
one time one flip okay my my memory is
longer i guess than 10 years and i'm
perceiving flips that that you are not
thank you
okay follow up um so this one this one's
actually more intellectual um
this one so you said in your testimony
you thought
uh
the best map would be one that had urban
suburban and rural and you the league of
women voters is a part of the mapathon
coalition
the fair maps people
who talks about all the time communities
of interests but you just described
splitting three communities of interest
so i'm kind of confused is
is how
like i'm confused at the messaging there
right we keep communities of interest
together oh no we should actually do a
suburban urban and rural district that's
two different things in my mind can you
explain the difference between that yes
i probably said it wrong so thank you
for that question so i can clarify
um
i think that that rural needs are very
different from urban needs from
industrial needs i think one somebody
earlier mentioned economic units such as
the greater manchester area
and that's a community of interest
but i think by the time you get to
congress
the congressional rep needs to
understand all of those communities of
interest
and ideally
in my humble opinion a congressional
district would
include whatever there is in the state
and have samples of all of those
so that's what i was trying to say
representative barry and i may not be
saying it very well and i apologize
further questions
representative lane and then
uh
thank you um
how do you feel that there's not going
to be any public hearings on any further
proposed maps
that's something we've been fighting for
since uh 2011
that we need public hearings
and i'm happy that we're having this one
i think if there are other amendments
and other proposals there should be
public hearings
we don't want a repetition
of what happened in 2011 that left
voters
and even legislators completely
frustrated so any further maps should
have public hearings in my opinion
thank you
representative
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question so when you're
talking about splitting or communities
of interest how do you feel when we're
splitting the northern part of carroll
county and this amendment and giving
that over to cd2 and
yeah
so i don't i don't have the county maps
on my drawing i did try to draw it at
home but
but many parts of carroll county are
more like coast county aren't they in
their needs
in their issues
and so when those parts of carroll
county were included in district one
i think whoever was elected from
district one needed to take that into
account
in terms of votes in congress
so that's why i
would like something maybe closer to
the current maps
which
maybe could be made more competitive
somehow i'm not sure
but i don't think they're quite as
current maps meaning the 2011 maps i
don't think they're terrible
they are somewhat competitive and i'd
like to see them more competitive if
representative barry could move some
towns around make them so
so thank you
thank you for this opportunity
thank you
next neither in support or opposition
olivia zinke
good morning members of the special
committee on redistricting for the
record my name is olivia zing the
executive director of open democracy
action a non-partisan nonprofit pro
voter organization and i live in
franklin
um i'm here today to ask for senate bill
200 as amended to be amended again to
equalize population
i want to really briefly talk about
population equalization standard or one
person one vote the supreme court
interpreted our u.s constitution
in a 1964 ruling westberry versus
sanders which is a georgia fifth
really interpreting article one section
two of the new hampshire constitution
really around equalization standard or
one pers the principle of one person one
vote and i think
it it does this committee
should work towards trying to get
districts with equal population
i want to also talk about a new jersey
court case
that rejected a point
six
nine eight four deviation
on the population equalization standard
and then another west virginia case
around population
deviation i think it's important for us
to understand that
my understanding of this map
and there was two different maps passed
around one had brookline in it and one
had when one didn't but the amendment
text
does have brook hold on brookfield
brookfield in it um so i have it as a
plus a hundred and uh
715 people and a negative
716 people
giving it a total population change of
1431 people and a deviation of 0.021
this is a population deviation that does
is in the threshold of the court
but we could do better
one way to do better on this proposed
amendment is taking the town of loudon
and switching it for epsom if you switch
that you get a population
plus 26 people and negative 27 people
for a total of 53 people changed with a
deviation of
0.01
population
this makes adjustments for more equal
representation
senate bill 200
100 as amended is more competitive than
the previous proposal but less
competitive than the current map
redistricting impacts our daily lives
and drawing these lines
is really important around how
resources are allocated to new hampshire
for hospitals schools roads
and they're very critical
to answer
representative weber's question this map
shifts 25 towns for a total population
shifted of 152
thirty
seven people
um
what this map does
is it takes the vast majority of the
north count country out
and only keeping north country
represented by one district
and i think it's important for people
who live in northern new hampshire to
have
a representation
my take of this map and just
is that it doesn't recognize a lot of
communities of interest
and cohes
cohesiveness
and if you are looking for ideas for an
another compromise amendment you could
put all of belknap carol stratford and
rockingham county plus manchester and
pelham if you put those four counties
and those two towns together you'd have
a plus 22
or plus plus 21 negative 20
to 22 for a 43 people difference and a
zero deviation by keeping those counties
together so if keeping counties together
you could put four counties manchester
and pelham in one district
for a compromise amendment so those are
two ideas
and i also have testimony from
a voter in tamworth
to talk about who talks a little bit
about
keeping the north country together and a
voter in durham who was unable to attend
today
and with that i'm happy to take
questions
thank you actually i have one
in the court cases that you cited with
the deviation issues
the cases that we've looked at
if we just had to go to a perfect
population as close as we could get we
wouldn't need the committee because it
would be a math exercise when they go to
court they defend the population
deviation based on the rational basis
for the plan
was that what made those
cases fail or actually i guess i should
ask did they fail
going into court you justify a rational
basis so what happened
the new jersey court did reject the
population deviation although the west
virginia case accepted a 0.79
maximum population deviation but you're
right redistricting
there's lots of factors that go into
redistricting and i think the reason i
didn't check a support or a pose is i
really hope that the legislative process
can draw this map and it's not done by
the courts
it might end up being done by the courts
the court has already there's already
been a court case filed on this map and
they cited one of the ways that the
court's going to look at it is in the
least changed approach
and so when we look you know i don't
know how the court will define that
criteria but i think it's important
for the public to have confidence in the
map and know what the definitions of of
all of these are
thank you
representative weber
thank you and welcome back uh i just
wanted for
clarification um
in the paragraph where you talk about
uh switching the towns of loudoun and
the towns of
and epsom
is that switching them for the current
map or switching them from the
governor's map
from this amendment
um if you look at
um sorry amendments
um so you're talking about the amendment
that we're considering right now 1523
and
and loudon currently is in
the first district and i if you moved
loud into the second district swapping
that for epsom you get a much better
population deviation and i don't think
it changes any of the partisanship
those towns are very comparable in
merrimack county thank you very much
appreciate the clarification
representative barry um yes thank you um
i want to discuss uh the issue of
competitiveness so you said that
this proposed map
is less competitive the governor's map
is less competitive than the existing
map
i took issue that with miss tantarelli
from the league women voters i'm going
to take issue with that with you
one party has won 90 of the contests in
the last decade
you're saying that this map is going to
be less competitive than that so is it
going to go to zero one parties that's
gonna win everything what's the
definition of competitive here because
for me once again it's outcome
i i was using the 2020 election and i
was actually using the presidential
elections which is
you can you can judge competitiveness on
other on things i was looking at
actually who won the presidential race
in 2020 based on pure voter numbers um
and the house bill 52
um had about a ten percent
uh partisan
[Music]
uh
favors favoritism using the 2020
election results whereas this map had a
plus
three or four
um and i can pull those numbers and
email them to you and you and you can
you can look at the competitiveness
using different election results and i
think new hampshire is a purple state
where
different election results can give you
different measures of competitiveness
but i was using the 2020 election
numbers which i know is a higher
percent turnout than we've had in
previous elections follow
follow up um i i think this may uh uh
keep keep grounded to your chair here we
may agree on more than you believe
um so i'm if it's okay if the chairman
will indulge me i'm going to do a series
of do we agree if we can't do we agree
that
counties should be kept together
representative barry
you can ask one question all right do
you believe that counties should be kept
together as much as possible
i do okay man i said one more from us
one more yeah do you believe that major
economic communities should be kept
together i do thank you
thank you
representative
thank you mr chair um following my
colleague from manchester's land of
thinking um
do you believe that there are you know
that certain candidates can outperform
maybe their district's competitiveness
i i think new hampshire is a very purple
state i brought a purple marker with me
today hoping that the one line that you
can draw
um down the
state
is a purple line because we we have the
majority of voters as undeclared voters
and i think
candidates performances can change based
on the candidate and and how they're
attracting
undeclared voters and every new
hampshire election is unique in that way
but i do think it's important that
voters have faith that their vote
matters and by drawing compact and
competitive districts
does increase voters faith that their
vote matters in that election
representative land
uh thank you mr chair um
i i couldn't write it down fast enough
so i would just ask you to clarify
the three counties that you said could
be kept together
in the last sentence of my testimony um
it's belknap carol strafford rockingham
and then you have to take manchester and
pelham just to make the population so
just the two towns there in hillsborough
county and that does is a
is a zero deviation
um and it change its the difference of
43 people
thank you
so if you wanted to keep counties
together that's the best way to do that
thank you um comment you just made a few
minutes ago talked about uh voter
confidence and competitiveness
when one party as uh representative
barry mentioned before wins 90
of the elections over the last decade
would you say that the vote of
confidence and in those districts uh for
one party who was not on the winning
side might be
compromised
um i think that
as we had discussed earlier i think that
candidates matter in these races and
undeclared voters matter in these races
and i think new hampshire is one of only
a handful of states i think there's 18
considered competitive districts
throughout the country and both of new
hampshire districts are actually
considered
competitive in those
districts throughout the country so i i
do believe that new hampshire has been i
mean that's been a
a factor that's been widespread reported
follow up thank you mr chairman so is it
your opinion that the current districts
that we've um had for the last 10 years
are competitive
i think we've seen carol shea-porter and
frank guinta switch back and forth
um
i i think that you know when this
was originally drawn
i i think that we've you if a candidate
from either party could win either
district
representative barry how many times has
cd2 gone back and forth in the last 10
years
i don't i mean i think congresswoman
custer has had that
i don't remember how many elections but
i think prior elections it was charlie
bass
who has had that
congressional district 2
but not in the last 10 years so in its
current form it has never gone back and
forth because charlie bass was
congressman basically was elected in
2010 on a different map
so in the current maps configuration
cd2 has gone back and forth how many
times in the current configuration
democrats have won that with paul hodes
and nanny custer
representative weber
is your recollection the same as mine
that there was very very little change
in the congressional maps and the
redistricting of
2011 2012.
that is my memory and actually there's
been little change in 140 years on
congressional districts
um changing towns
follow up
and was is it your memories it is mine
that the only changes were made were
small changes along the borders to
equalize the population changes from the
previous ten years
yes and i believe that's what
uh article one section two of the new
hampshire constitution
asks this committee to do and can to
consider in drawing maps
represent barry hogg in the action it's
it's it's one of those days
um
you just mentioned that there's been
very little change since the 1880 map i
don't want to hold it up because i don't
want to get in trouble um
but um
i have it in front of me chairman
griffin distributed it
the deviation would be 300 000 people so
why while the towns may not be numerous
the population is undoubtedly numerous
so
you're is it fair to cite that as a
metric when we're talking about a
population difference of 300 000 people
if we were to have the current map as is
apparently the gold standard
um i think when you look at this it
keeps those four counties together that
i talked about that you could do um you
would have to then if you take the
uh 1880 map you would then need
manchester and pelham not the other
towns in merrimack and rockingham
counties
but you could keep those four counties
together like the 1880
map but i think
our population has shifted drastically
from now until 1880.
representative mcguire
thank you mr chair would you believe
that i went back to the 2011
committee reports and the minority was
objecting to the congressional map on
the because it moved too many towns from
one district to another
i would believe that
all right thank you
oh this writing's so tiny
linda bundy
and
well it says opposition and then says
neutral
slightly
yeah thank you
good morning vice chair vice chairman
smith and members of the special
committee on redistricting my name is
linda bundy and i'm from antrim
and i am neutral um i such a rule
follower that if there's pro and con i
just i didn't i don't right outside the
lines very often so
um i signed in remotely as neutral and
that is how i feel
um i believe that bringing this
amendment forward rather than sending hb
52 to the governor is a positive step
these maps do improve upon those
the seacoast towns remained in in
district one which respects the wishes
of the majority of the voters who live
there
these maps move less than half the
number of people to a new district
compared to the legislature's maps
making them less disruptive
the proposed maps are more competitive
than those in hb 52 although district 1
slightly republican and district
excuse me two leans democratic
the population deviation for these maps
is greater compared to the legislative
maps
and i also cited that by moving on these
maps epsom to district 1 and loudoun to
district 2 could improve that with a
difference of only 53 compared to 1431.
i ask you to amend this map by
decreasing the population deviation and
increasing the competitiveness
basic changes can better align these
maps with the requests of new hampshire
voters i do also ask though if there are
further amendments that there be
hearings for public comment
and i thank you for this opportunity i
also want to thank you for all the work
that this committee has put in
on redistricting
thank you thank you
does anyone else wish to be heard on
amendment 1523h
seeing none we'll close a public hearing
on the amendment
okay
thank you for conducting that hearing
thank you to members and
members of the public for participating
um that
concludes the business of this committee
for today
we do have a meeting next week
because in accordance with our own house
deadlines i i would like to get
something else out of this committee if
we can next week
i would like to get whatever we consider
up on the website i was able to get the
what we consider today up uh you know
last week i think cause we had it
but to the extent anybody has any maps
that they would like to consider at a
ols if you can get them to me we will
get them online we we've got a pretty
good committee assistance
and a researcher here who's pretty good
about getting in touch with it as soon
as i have something about getting it
online and if you can if you get an
amendment out of ols because of course
that's how we need it is as an official
amendment
um if you've got a
a picture
as much as i'm really sort of opposed to
the picture approach
um let's get that also online
um and just make sure that it matches
whatever the ols amendment is because
just so everybody knows for the record
we are not getting the maps from ols
all
ols does is draft the amendment with the
towns and then the people who have been
sponsoring these amendments have been
generating the map to go with it which
is what committee members have had in
front of them
so we will see you all next week thank
you everybody for coming this morning
you